- Welcome to auction school!
(upbeat banjo music)
- 11 dollar bid and now 12,
now 12, who'll gimme 12?
- [Group] Five, five,
five, five and a quarter,
five and a quarter, five
and a half, five and a half,
- Will you give me 20,
will you give me 20?
10, 10, 20, 20.
- [Group] Eight and a
quarter, eight and a quarter,
nine, nine, nine and a quarter.
10 and a half, 10 and a
half, 75, 75, sold!
- Give yourselves a hand, good job!
- What 5,000, what five,
and I want one, five, two.
- Here biddin' a two, here
biddin' a two and three
three and four, here biddin',
- Sold to buyer number 122,
here we go, rock and roll.
- The Missouri Auction School was founded
in 1905, it's the oldest and largest
auction school in the world.
It trains auctioneers in
every aspect of the auction
profession and is known as
the Harvard of auctioneering.
- Introduce the item,
as for 10, drop to five,
I'll give you the five,
and then go to six.
So we start every
morning at auction school
with group drills.
- [Group] Betty Botter bough some butter.
Buddy said his butter's bitter.
Eight and a quarter, eight and a quarter,
eight and half, eight and
half, 90, 90, 80, 80, 70, 70.
- Just like an athlete would
warm up, we need to warm up.
Very good, okay, give
yourselves a hand, good job!
At auction school, the
most important aspect
is that auction chant.
- At a 100, now get a-two, three.
- One dollar bid and now two, now two.
- Two dollar bid and now three and three.
- 20 dollar bid, now 25, 25 now, and sold.
- It's the very foundation
of the auction profession.
I'm at 20 dollar bid and now 30, now 30,
will you gimme 30, I'm at 20 dollar bid.
Okay, let's try that.
The auction chant is two
numbers, the money that you
have bid and the money
that you're asking for.
I have one dollar bid, now two,
now two, will you gimme two?
- I'm at two dollar bid and now three,
now three, will you gimme three?
I'm at two dollar bid.
- Will you gimme 20,
will you you gimme 20?
- Feel that?
- Now 50, now 50 will you gimme 50?
That's it, that's it!
Good job!
And as they sell more and
more, those filler words
will slur so it'll move
a little bit faster.
- A dollar 70, dollar 70,
dollar bid and now one,
now one dollar bid and now two.
- 17, 17, will you gimme 17?
Got a dollar 16, 17, 17 will you gimme 17?
- Will you gimme 42, I'm
at 41, will you gimme 42,
I'm at 42, thank you sir.
- I'm at 400, even 400
dollar, four, sold, 375!
And that's what creates that
nice smooth rhythm chant.
- Rubber baby buggy
bumper, basic rhythm, 'kay?
- Learning the auction
chant in a classroom setting
is important, but you're
not really an auctioneer
until you get to go to a real auction
and sell real items to real people.
- Dollar's five, somebody bid six dollars,
who woulda bid six?
- [Baseball Cap] Dollar bid--
- [Striped Shirt] Yup!
- She said three, she said three.
- Five dollar, woulda bid six
dollars, who woulda bid six?
Five, someone'd bid six?
- Yup!
- Sold, five dollars your way.
- So at the student auction,
you never know what's gonna
come up for sale and so you
gotta be ready for anything.
- First item's lot 75, you
got a stack of three turtles.
- We got an old tablecloth.
- Jumper cables, very useful.
- Ooh, a cuckoo clock!
- It looks like another stack of turtles.
- Lot number 663, it's a meat cleaver.
- Yup!
- So one of the most fascinating aspects
of the process is the transformation
that the students make
throughout the program.
So often when they first
come to the school,
they're hesitant, they aren't
sure what they're doing.
A lot of them are frightened, even.
Once they get up and they
sell and they realize,
"Yes, I can do this,
I can really do this!"
You can hear it in their
voice, "I'm an auctioneer."
- 15 dollar bid and now 20, now 20,
would you gimme 20 bid, now 25.
- Give yourselves a hand, great job.
(clapping)
That was really good.
Good job.
Okay, now let's do the chant.
We'll go up to nine, we'll come back down.